bonsoir jean luc le gall merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
ce soir en temps normal pas assez de
médecins sur certains territoires et en
temps de crise avec des jets rennes avec
des généralistes en première ligne pour
vacciner
comment est ce qu'on fait d'autant plus
qu'il annonce inquiète tomber tout à
l'heure la vaccination chez les
généralistes démarre le 25 février
oui tout à fait la crise du coc vie de
augmente aux commandes la difficulté la
problématique elle en plus elle n'est
pas que dans l'est dans les cantons
ruraux la problématique aller les
général on la retrouve aussi dans des
dans des grandes villes impôts pour
l'exemple de ma commune à toulon dans un
simple quartier en leven départ de douze
généralistes ont condamné entre 10000 et
12000 patients qui ont du mal à trouver
un médecin traitant
donc s'il va être très compliqué pour
ces gens là d'avoir accès effectivement
des sous traitants pour se faire
vacciner comme les très compliqué
d'avoir médecin traitant pour ce que
j'ai à prendre en charge que les
médecins présents restent reste débordé
mais alors comment est ce qu'on fait
qu'est ce que vous proposez pour trouver
une solution à cela c'est problématique
la solution je pense que tous les
patients réussiront un le fait de pas
voir médecin traitant de n'empêche pas
l'accès à la vaccination un certain
nombre de médecins accepteront de
prendre en charge des patients qui ne
suivent pas habituellement ça sera sans
doute un peu plus compliqué le chemin
sera plus cahoteux et malheureusement la
solution c'est une problématique qui
dure depuis des années de voir des
dizaines d'années qui était plus ou
moins annoncé que les pouvoirs
politiques n'ont pas souhaité nous
considérer au prendre en charge on
n'arrivera pas à régler cette
problématique dans les semaines ou dans
les mois à venir
ça dure depuis des années en scène c'est
pas nouveau mais avec cette crise
sanitaire cette crise du corona virus ça
revient au premier plan à ce que du coup
c'est pas j'ai envie de dire l'occasion
de sa terrasse problème est de trouver
les solutions il faut aussi ajouter ça
fait longtemps qu'on aurait dû 2.2
décharné les facteurs les raisons sont
multifactorielles la crise du corps vide
là sans doute aggraver les choses mais
il faut savoir quand même de deux mille
attraits du corry de l'activité des
médecins libéraux dans l'ensemble a b c
en france est sur l'année 2020
l'activité a baissé de abaissé de 20%
donc d'abord parce que en mars avril on
avait demandé aux gens de rester chez
eux donc elle ça a été des mois et des
mois où les gens se sont pas pris en
charge
effectivement pendant cette année aussi
doit de médecins sont partis en retraite
n'ont pas été remplacés
les solutions argent les trouvais ça va
prendre plusieurs années je leur ai
motiver les confrères à revenir vers la
médecine libérale à la fois en relais à
la fois dans les milieux dans les néo
ruraux a créé des structures d'accueil
d'activités regrouper parce que c'est le
souhait des jeunes des jeunes
générations et christine nécessité
impérative du fait maintenant des
complications administratives de la
profession justement vous parlez des
complications administratives
on évoque souvent la lourdeur
administrative les millefeuilles
décisionnel les ars notamment les
agences régionales de santé qui sont
pointés les technostructures en quoi
est-ce à dire une difficulté pour pour
les déserts médicaux
vous savez dans les airs médicaux il ya
tout un tas de mesures qui ont d'ores et
déjà été mises en place par les
différents pouvoirs politiques des aides
à l'installation de d d d aide à la
prise en charge des locaux l'éventuelle
maintenant des lots se détend de
secrétariat tout ça je suis pas certain
que ce soit la rs au niveau des parts au
niveau départemental ou au niveau
régional qui sont responsables de ces
difficultés là il ya deux mois n'a
calculé
l'attractivité du métier est une charge
administrative important que de lydie
médecins en tant que tel dans son
cabinet d'un médecin généraliste non à
mon avis ne peut plus démarre une
activité de tous tout seul et son
secrétaire en tout cas dans quel état
d'esprit sont les habitants des
populations rurales face à face au
vaccin méfiance réticence ou espoirs a
contrario on pointe souvent un certain
scepticisme
41% des français veulent
se faire vacciner selon un sondage
récent du 5 février
certes cher pour software je sais pas si
c'est propre aux populations virale je
crois qu'on a la même chose le même
pourcentage dans les populations
urbaines
on a aussi d'un certain nombre de
soignants de personnes le chantier qui
sont aussi réticents et tout un tas de
discours quand la venue sur les réseaux
sociaux dans les médias qui n'ont fait
que ce que l'on craignait une certaine
confusion et certain scepticisme
je pense que de toute façon l'état
actuel de toute façon on n'a pas
suffisamment de doses pour vacciner le
carnet des 59 ou 50 % qui sont prêts à
se faire vacciner
la problématique et les jeunes et en cas
de test positif aux convives 19 la rs
précise qu'il est possible d'avoir la
visite d'une infirmière libérale comment
est ce qu'on fait quand ça se passe là
où les infirmiers sont peu nombreux dans
les zones géographiquement étendue les
iem firme annonce est pas ma spécialité
mais ils sont ils sont un peu plus
nombreux que nous ils ont une activité
les infirmiers libéraux qui est un peu
différent qui sont beaucoup plus dans
l'association
ce sont des gens qui font quasiment que
du domicile donc ils sont habitués à se
déplacer chez les gens donc ça s'est mis
en place de façon très claire dans les
départements au travers des possédants
deux affirmé des associations les
facilités en général en tout cas dans
d'autres départements pour les services
de la cpam afrique
j'ai une dernière question par rapport à
la vidéo consultation est ce que c'est
une
une solution par rapport à aux problèmes
rencontrés dans les déserts médicaux
c'est une journée sur une solution mais
c'est aussi une solution en ville c'est
une solution qui a été admise été mise
en place début de l'épidémie dès le mois
de mars qui a rendu beaucoup de services
à ce que beaucoup de gens rechignent à
se déplacer dans les cabinets médicaux
par peur d'attraper le coc vide et qui
parce qu'on a me dis à tout le monde de
surtout ne vous dépassez pas chez le
médecin beaucoup de consultations était
transformée comme ça c'est la solution
effectivement ça fait partie des
solutions tout cas merci jean luc le
gall d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le président du
conseil de l'ordre des médecins du var